we begin with some breaking news out of
china a passenger plane carrying 133
people has crashed in the south of the
country the boeing 737 came down in the
countryside near wujo in the guangxi
region of the country state media says
the number of casualties isn't known
katrina you is joining us from beijing
katrina what more are you hearing about
this crash in this particularly
mountainous area of china
well there seems to be a
very disastrous accident and fears are
growing concerning the lives of those on
board it's a developing story we're
still getting some details but this is
what we know so far it was a boeing 737
passenger plane and it left the southern
city of kunmi in the province of yunnan
at about 1 15 pm local time now it was
headed to the city of guangzhou which is
not far from hong kong and that flight
should have only taken less than two
hours they're not very far away but
before uh obviously it did not arrive at
its destination and instead the plane
has crashed in guangxi province which is
a very rural mountainous area we've seen
some social media posts online some
videos showing um scenes of what
purports to be the crash of this plane
it seems that there has been a wildfire
caused by the plane coming down and
really you can get a sense of how remote
this area is now chinese state media
says there are rescue teams on the way
and because of how difficult this
terrain is you can see that it's not
going to be easy to get rescue teams
there
very very quickly now china's civil
aviation authority have confirmed the
crash they say that there were
132 people on board including uh
including the crew as well now we don't
know any more details regarding how many
casualties there might be what might
have caused uh this crash but this has
already caused a lot of shock especially
on social media china has quite a good
record of aviation safety uh accidents
like this are extremely rare the last
time we had any sort of plane incident
or plane crash was in 2010 and before
that uh the
other incident was in 2004 so this
doesn't happen very frequently at all
but even those incidents they involved
fewer than 100 people so this is
definitely the biggest aviation incident
that we've had in china for
years
yes it certainly doesn't look
encouraging those shots are awful thank
you very much for that update katrina
you live for us in beijing